All he does is lie about me. Like, what am I supposed to think
here? This is >> He actively propagated Destiny's lies
about me, right? Him and Willie both have done that for a while.
And then Destiny's lies that Willie propagated about Queen. I
got to be honest with you, there there is some charitability
that I still have for this guy. What? Why?
Why? Kind of an important thing to be lying about constantly.
Dude, Nicholas is unaware that Destiny got a deal from the FBI.
Okay, guys. is if you're not aware, if Destiny exposes three,
they let him go on the child stuff. Okay. The fact that somebody
could talk him into making a video on I I did not talk him into
making a video, that is also a complete lie.
Like a big influencer, guys. These guys deserve a lot of [__]
criticism for that. Okay. Like, yeah, that's all I'll say. You
guys are really lucky to have the jobs you have. You guys are
really lucky you still have the jobs you have. Um, you should
that should reflect more, I think, in your cander, I would say.
>> Okay. You guys are very lucky to have your jobs. That
should reflect more in your cander. I don't know if he goes to
anything else here. I think we got to be
is not going to go after him. Okay, hold on. I think that's it.
I think that's like it for this stream. So, we'll go to the the
Nicholas thing and then after the Nicholas thing, I think we're
basically done here. I figured I'm already too >> ready
to go with what he put out a manifesto said that he wanted like
basically the right and the left to be >> I super don't
care about this super don't care
>> even gives you to talk about JF just for context right
I said the clip of Destiny fighting with his chat about how it
would be weird to date a 19-year-old was not out of context nothing
about the debate subject is important to understand that part
and that's what Destiny has chosen I guess to call me out on
>> uh Destiny explicitly strips that context away. >> I
guess my malice or my bad research and then when you watch the
actual clip, he has this to say. >> Maybe if he wasn't
watching Nicholas Fat Oreo stream, maybe he would actually have
some actual context of what those conversations about. But you
know what? Listen, I love the clip champion. Do it more. I love
it. Okay. >> Okay, I will. But just to be clear, all right,
I don't agree with every single thing that Ethan says here. In
my own coverage, I referred to some of it as uncharitable. And
it's also building off of prior clips to make an overall narrative
argument.
In regards to the context, though, let's hear what Destiny has
to say to defend himself before I tell you why I'm right. >> This
one comes to you courtesy of the Pope, uh, Nicholas Dioro,
uh, or whatever it is they do. >> God bless. >> God
bless. Nicholas bless >> years old. That's an adult. That's
an adult dog. No.
No. Okay. I'm 29. A 19-year-old might as well be a 15-year-old
to me. It's okay. That's That's the wor That's the worst. Yeah,
that's the worst clip. >> Okay, I actually already did
all of this stuff to show the context, right? Where is the part?
Does he actually he gets to Destiny's stream tonight, right?
And starts covering it and talking about how they lied cuz I
already showed exactly like where all this was coming from. We've
gone over it. I don't need to >> That's why all these guys
want women that are 20 years old cuz they're too stupid to pick
the
Oh, wait. We've got another clip, too. Hold on. You guys see
that tweet? That tweet's really good, too. and divorcing and
cheating on Lauren Southern. Uh yeah, she was like 18, 19, 20,
right? Like in that exact in that that maybe that maybe that's
when the divergence happened, but I I don't know. I don't know.
Maybe he's morally consistent. Who knows? This is what was posted
here. I explained that the clip of Destiny fighting with his
chat about how it would be weird to date a 19-year-old girl was
not out of context. Nothing about the date subject is important
to understand that part. I think this is fundamentally true.
I think I have demonstrated this fundamentally true. I think
this was an argument that Destiny had. Maybe it was years ago,
maybe not anymore. Maybe he brought it back during the Red Pill
arc cuz those people are like onlogically evil or something.
Um, but like I think that it is hilarious that Destiny has had
these positions and then found himself in a situation like the
one with Rose, like the ones with Molina. Like I I do think that
is >> Well, I think during the Red Pill arc, people who
had known Destiny for a while, like John Zurka, pointed out that
like, dude, you're totally disingenuous on this. This is totally
fake. Destiny, this is totally fake, buddy. >> Hey, buddy.
I'm sorry. I'm behind on stream, but you use the same tactics
you're condemning Destiny for for dividing Lib and Learn. Okay,
go ahead, Kingler. Lay out your uh lay lay out your argument.
Actually, Kingler, why don't you just hop on the stream?
Just hop on the stream and explain this the same tactics to me.
So, yeah, I I defend the out of this tweet. But again, Destiny
is calling my research into question right now. The only problem
with that, right, remember what was the uh the lines
here specifically? I enforce really high standards when it comes
to clipping and attacking people. The outof context bull doesn't
happen in my community for that reason. This is the claim
>> that he made, right? But like 12 hours earlier, this
guy put out a tweet saying uh he responded substantially to uh
substantively to everything. He didn't. Oreo counters by showing
a clip of him with Dan in a pregame lobby like I'm making out
a serious claim. Thank you for lining them up for me. All you
do is make me look better in the long run fatty. This is a great
tweet. I have no problem with the argument made in this tweet
except for one small problem.
It's a equ thing. >> That's not me. That's not my video.
That's not my stream. I've never seen this clip before, Mr. I
do all the best research on planet Earth. That's not me. The
rich history with obsessively making jokes, everything else.
>> It is very funny that somebody must have told them like,
"Oh, this is look at the look at them going after you." And just
not knowing who anyone was. >> Nobody on my stream. We
do not normalize. Sad embarrassing. I can never >> O. Oh,
where is it? Uh. Oh, wrong button. Hold on. Wait, wait. Wrong
button. Wrong button. Uh, where is it? >> O. Hey, Nicholaso
has none of them principles, mate. Willie M show. Yeah.
>> So, again, this is where uh Nicholas Quigler uh has
been doctorred to have an Zmpic t-shirt on and a little Palestinian
flag in his punch bowl. And there's a little skull in the uh
the coconut here. Okay. So, Nicholas totally owned doing this.
Very funny.
>> Yeah, cherry or something. Yeah, do that. There we go.
Is that what you That's not me. That's another guy wiggling.
You saw somebody dancing and you thought it was me. >> Miners.
I've never >> It's very funny that he he decided to be
a passive aggressive whiny [__] there. Okay. Just
the most feminine whiny [__] there. Okay. And he
does it with an Ozmpic t-shirt on. Okay. You're owned, Nicholas.
You're [__] owned. It's over. Okay. Pack it up, buddy.
So, yeah.
I think it's f. I don't know. I I think it's insane. Thank you
for what? >> Oh. Uh, you had a second example. That's fantastic.
Should have brought a first example up for me, dude. This tweet's
still up. He doesn't care. You know why? Cuz it's sending people
to my socials. That's why I didn't even [__] say
This tweet's correct. This is correct. You're wrong. I'm sorry.
But that's against that's just another point. How about Yeah.
So, I kept this up in case he deleted it while I was streaming.
So, yeah. Not only is Destiny L it's like such a sad waste of
time. It's so goofy to to like I like I like talking to people.
I like engaging in like debate, but when somebody just won't
engage with what you're saying. I don't want to talk about that.
Okay. Why did you Why did you on the stream? In his post, he
literally published a tweet crying about me within the last 24
hours. The clip that he researched was not even me. He actively
refuses to take it down because he's more interested in slandering
people than actually being correct. So, I hope that explains
that.
up next. Okay, this clip we showed the other night. All right,
this is an example of Destiny talking about how he hates being
clipped out of context. Every single time some insane person
releases some random screenshot or piece of paper or whatever
that I'm going to come and run through all these communities
and try to give some crazy explanation for whatever else. Because
one, the only thing that's happening is I see that every single
thing I possibly say gets either misconstrued or drawn out to
the most absurd reality possible. Yeah, I hate when that happens,
Destiny. I hate when people literally take something and twist
it to make it sound way worse than it actually was. >> Where
Nicholas Oreo cakes or whatever is saying that I'm threatening
Willy's wife because I said she was a massage agent. >> I
did not say that you threatened Willy's wife. I said that you
targeted Willy's wife because after he reported you to the police
for what he believed was a justifiable reason. And I agree with
him. Okay. You started going in and making the jokes that bad
empanada was making when they do his wife in your >> Uh-oh.
Uh oh. >> Chat. Oh, I don't like Willick. >> Nick,
don't sorry about the jokes. Nick. Nick, that's the problem.
That's the thing Ethan did wrong. Nickmore. So, I'm gonna [__]
lean into the Yeah, it's obviously a joke. No, you're not threatening
Willy's wife. There's nothing even remotely close to a threat.
Okay, that is a huge escalation of what I said. >> Absurd
reality possible. >> But guys, guys, guys, he does
You said he was targeting his wife, which like technically you
could say, okay, he he had, you know, made a joke about his wife,
right? You could say that's targeting's wife. I think targeting
has a loading to it. If we want to pretend it doesn't have a
loading, it's it's just saying what direction your joke is pointed
in. If we want to pretend that that's all it is, then I we can
that's fine.
guys. Guys,
no out of context.
Really high standards. Okay. Awesome, dude. to where Nicholas
Oreo cakes or whatever is saying >> I don't understand
why that would be different from what Hassan did in any way but
you know >> I'm threatening Willy's wife because I said
she was a MSAD agent which I have to clarify was a joke okay
I wasn't a >> he's trying to meme through it >> you
know we're not talking right about right now >> that was
a meme an obvious joke unfortunately like that that one oh dude
that one is rough because I don't think there's a way to interpret
that seriously Right. Like like there are ways when Destiny when
Destiny like argues that um
or when Destiny says he has like um I'm trying to think of like
sometime he's joked he said something was a joke when it was
serious. There's not a double meaning to that. There's no universe
where Destiny thinks that Willie Matt's wife is a mad agent.
That doesn't exist. >> You know we're not actually that
universe doesn't exist at all sitting here having a conversation
about probably like the most important thing here. Okay. Destiny
and Willie Max interaction. This is a tweet that Destiny posted
last night. Now, I have my own version of it. I'll show you it
in a minute. Right? Obviously, it's a reference to uh Raja Jackson
or whatever. Rampage Jackson's son who beat the out of the guy
in the octagon.
Right? So, Willie Max is like, "Whoa." Huh. That's actually probably
a better example. Yes. Anytime he talked about being a was a
better example of him joking where it's a little concerning versus
the Willie Max's wife thing where there's just no universe where
he thinks Willie Mac's wife was in the id. >> Oh no. Destiny,
what are you >> in Mad in Mad Mad doing? Right. >> Okay.
So, let's take a look at this.
>> I should go back to this. I'll probably go back to this
afterwards just to >> The joke is when he says Gen. >> Actually,
no. Hold on. Wait. Before we get to the Willy Mro thing, I do
want to wrap up this segment right here. Sorry. I totally forgot.
I have to go back here because you know what's funny? You know
what the best part of this whole segment was? And I totally just
completely ruined my my flow. Uh, Destiny, I think, realizes
I'm right mid conversation. And I need you to see it. >> That's
because of some illegal age of consent bull. Huh. That's the
age of consent. We I think we all agree that's a good thing.
Everyone but Destiny thinks that's good. We should have again
this is super uncharitable. It's also not my argument. >> A
minimum age so that adults can't have with children. Um that
is bull. That is just an imagined line in the sand that I will
not conform to. Okay. He's he's
>> Okay. So this idea of me saying that the age of consent
is bull. That's not at all what I'm saying there. >> So
now he goes and shows the additional >> at all. Like it
was the exact opposite argument that just because this girl was
19 years old, >> we ran through this. I'm going to skip
through. Uh >> he's got the Willy Mack clip from today
up and ready to go. I actually This is actually most of what
I wanted to watch, okay? Was Nicholas's response to Destiny just
transparently like like kind of just creative writing about the
two of them. Okay. And the spin is outrageous. Okay. Although
the funny thing is is I said I was engaging creative writing
when I pointed it out. Okay. I said from the first second that
through the schizosphere I was interpreting. Okay. And I believed
that that Willie would have asked Nicholas if it was okay to
make that video. If he would have he would have asked him what
to do with those DMs that he wouldn't have had his own thought
process. He is not a conscious being and he would have filtered
it all through Nicholas Dioro. Okay, I predicted that and I do
believe a lot of that came true. Okay, I believe that was that
was actually real. You need to hear the spin. >> The I
don't know if I don't know how public these videos are or if
they've spread it all, but like the only reason Willie made that
video is because um Nicholas Dioro told him to. Okay, bro. Um,
excuse me.
Awesome. Thank you so much for that. I really do appreciate it.
>> Willie, the I don't know if I don't know how public
these videos are or if they've spread it all, but like the only
reason Willie made that video is because um Nicholas Dioro told
him to. >> Dude, Willie hit me up after my stream and the
DM literally started out with, I have reported Destiny to law
enforcement. I want to call you. And the two things that he was
wondering on whe what what he should do is if he should make
the video now or if it could potentially damage a legal thing.
He should wait to see if anything happens with the police first.
So all I told him cuz again this video was always coming out.
Okay? And and I'll tell you when it was coming out because obviously
Destiny has an issue with some timeline stuff here. I'll tell
you when it became a video and when it was just an interview.
But just to be clear, Willie was always posting this. He just
didn't know if he was posting it now or later. That that was
literally >> I it kind of sucks for Willie that Nicholas
seems to have come in and said no no no you can post it now.
I don't know why Nick would have done this >> because he's
like well the victim I go dude if this guy actually has on his
>> it's not about the victim. It's about the investigation
>> computer. They don't have to wait for the victim. They
can get his hard drives. I don't know if that's right or wrong.
I was trying to get a lawyer's opinion on it. I eventually did
and then it went public. So that was kind of the the the >> I
eventually did and then it went public. Wait, did it go public
based on that lawyer's opinion? What was that lawyer's opinion?
>> Uh, the talk of the day. I literally did not create
this controversy. I did not Hold on. Did you hear that? Did you
hear >> Wrong. I was trying to get a lawyer's opinion on
it. I eventually did and then it went public. So, >> I
eventually did and then it went public.
Now, listen. Listen. To me, that sounds like I got the opinion
and then it went public. Did was there an in between step there
where like you filtered that lawyer your like it going public
through that lawyer's opinion? I feel like a lawyer probably
would have also said maybe ask the cops. Am I crazy? That's just
common sense to me. Before you say that you
you tip the cops off that somebody's done something really bad
and that you publicly announce it without asking the cops if
you should do that, right? No, no, no, no. He's saying he got
the opinion from the lawyer, but he goes, "This guy actually
has on his computer. They don't have to wait for the victim.
They can get his hard drives." I don't know if that's right or
wrong. I was trying to get a lawyer's opinion on it. I eventually
did and then it went public. So that >> I they can get
his hard drives. They don't need the victim. But the issue is
the hard drives have to be there. Nothing's going to happen with
the police. Okay, that was kind of the the the uh the talk of
the day. I literally did not create this controversy. I did not
pressure Willie into disavowing Destiny. Literally completely
>> Willie the I don't know if I don't know how public these
videos are or if they've spread it all, but like the only reason
Willie made that >> dude Willie called me and goes, "Hi,
Mr. Cabal. Can I come back into the house? No, you can't come
back in the [__] house, mate. Now you're [__]
sweeping. You're [__] sweeping, man. >> Dude,
this guy is seething so badly. I This is really, by the way,
this is Nicholas had I I have to reveal the Nicholas effect.
Okay, Nicholas had precisely the exact right strategy for dealing
with Quean and Queen like kind of going after him. Okay, and
that is ignore completely.
That's the only strategy you can employ if you're in the wrong
and you have a critic who's like going after you hard. Okay,
just ignore it completely because engaging with them would be
bad, right?
You shouldn't go and do this like passive aggressive like feminine
thing where you do these little references,
okay? Cuz you are addressing it and you are being a now if you're
going to constantly reference him and and dodge, right? I'm just
saying it's like behavior. these videos are if they've spread
all like the only reason Willie made that >> Willie called
me and goes, "Hi, Mr. Cabal. Can I come back into the house?"
No, you can't come back in the house, mate. Nah, you're [__]
sweeping. You're [__] sweeping, man. >> None
of that makes any I don't even know what he's saying. Hi, Mr.
Cabal. So, he said that to Nicholas and then Nicholas was doing
the Queen imitation. I Okay, just to be clear, uh none of this
would maybe even be an issue if Nick had just pointed out that
Willie took Destiny. By the way, Destiny's word for it when when
Destiny told him Queman is doxed your wife. Someone in Queens
community doxed your wife. Willie made a video going only on
Destiny's word and no other information and said Quean doxed
me and my wife. Queman's fan, somebody in the Queen community
doxed mine and my wife's wedding. And Nicholas retweeted the
video, supported it, and then didn't watch it or criticize any
of that behavior. And then tonight he goes live and goes, "Oh,
it's really up how Destiny's just lying about me." Bro, you have
amplified and swept for Destiny's lies up until this point. You
and Willie both. I don't know why you're acting like I I have
no idea where you get off like now going, "Oh, it's so shocking
that he's lying about me." It's not shocking. Of course, he's
lying about you. Although,
we'll see what the lie is precisely. Okay. He probably takes
it too far. We'll see exactly what it is. But it's just it's
it's [__] up that Willie makes this video open just
maliciously lying, taking a Destiny narrative one to one that
Destiny later revealed he DM'd to Willie.
No evidence other than Destiny's word and he he runs that in
a video slanders me.
I think it's just me and Queman, but Queman more significantly
says Queman's directly responsible, right? No retraction, no
apology, no note. Didn't take the video down, didn't edit. Still
up as it was, right?
It's a totally malicious lie that was fed to him by Destiny.
Oh, Auggie, too. Yeah, exactly. And
me, I forgot. I forgot about Auggie. It's my bad. That's my bad.
Come on. And And we have to pretend that Nicholas isn't the right
here like totally making jokes about this. When we when we joke
about Willie sweeping, we talk about Willie sweeping. Not joke.
We talk about Willie sweeping. He's like, "Oh, this is totally
like this is totally made up." No, Willie has been amplifying
Jesse's lies about us for months.
Fun load. Oh, no, dude. Willie the I don't know if I don't know
how public these videos are or if they've spread it all, but
like the only reason Willie made that video is because um Nicholas
Dioro told him to. So, I I hold Willie just responsible though.
Um I didn't notice. I was going back and I was just rereading
through our messages or whatever. Um, thinking like what else
wanted to happen on and I realized that at the beginning of that
conversation like Willie is literally saying he literally says
he even has in his YouTube video although it's like half a second
it's like five frames um where he's like oh hey like I'm just
want more information about this. This is all off the record.
I'm not making a video on this of course and it's like oh so
I'm like not even I'm just like >> okay. So now he's accusing
Willie of hiding the DMs right just flashing them on screen.
Well, Willie did that because a they weren't as important as
the stuff that was actually important in the video that you're
not really going to address in any capacity. But like two, why
are we just pretending here? He published all the DMs separately.
You can go read all of them. They're literally attached to the
tweets. It's not like he's made an attempt to hide this stuff.
He gave it to people to read on stream, my guy. You just chose
not to watch it. >> Half me being through some of this
conversation. Depends on where you're at. Like Jesus Christ.
Um, yeah, the idea that like I mean it's it's his career. It's
his the fact that somebody could talk him into making a video
on I I did not talk him into making a video. That is also a complete
lie. Another from Destiny >> off the record information.
>> Again, dude, I got to be honest with you. There there
is some charitability that I still have for this guy. But all
why
was there some charitability that you still had? What the are
you saying?
What? Where did that charitability come from exactly? Guys, there
was some charitability that I still had for this guy. How? Why?
In what universe did this exist? All he does is lie about me.
Like, what am I supposed to think here? This is This is so crazy
that we're just all sitting here like, "Okay, you uh you he actively
propagated Destiny's lies about me, right? Him and Willie both
have done that for a while. And then he propagated Willy's lies
about Quean. Sorry, Destiny's lies that Willie propagated about
Queen. Like he he did this precisely. And now he's going, "Oh,
I can't believe Destiny would do this to
Why? Why can't you believe it? What are you shocked about? Kind
of an important thing to be lying about constantly.
>> I feel like it's kind of crazy unhinged, but hey, you
know what? That's life. Who cares? Ethan and Willie claim you
didn't respond to the one part. Can you please play that part
again showing you responded? It's all on my video. >> Oh,
it's all in your video. Meaning you watched the entire thing.
>> Wait, Willie lied with his conversation. You said it
was off the record. Yeah, I didn't notice until I went back and
I >> Okay, Willie said it was off the record. Yes. In the
beginning of the conversation, right? He's getting an update
for his video based off of new evidence that has come. This is
like the worst criticism you could do is Destiny. Um, he said
it was off the record unless he I gave him reason to be suspicious.
And then I told him that I have child actually right now that
I have it saved because of my court case. Like this is the only
criticism you can't make here or one of the few criticisms you
can't make. Like Willie objectively made the right decision being
super weirded out and not keeping this just like private and
off the record. Like obviously >> forward he's not currently
in the production of a new video. as an off-record conversation,
which by the way remained an off therecord conversation until
the part where you said that you had potential material on your
hard drive and then it became a conversation with local law enforcement.
I mean, it's really not a hard concept here, my guy. Listen,
you're a smart dude or at least you were before you became a
rage cow. But obviously, just to be clear, it's not 60 gigabytes.
That's a misunderstanding. a sort of understandable misunderstanding
that was Rose sent a screenshot saying she had 60 GB of photo
sets that her and her boyfriend had shot. Okay. Uh and she sent
a screenshot to Destiny showing the cloud storage size. But he
does say that he has the video still. There was something in
that conversation that escalated it from quick little checkup
and questioning to I've got to report this guy to the police
and I don't know if it's going to take a detective. I don't know
if Dr. House is going to come out here and try to diagnose what
happened. It's It seems like it's pretty obvious, you know? It
seems like there's not a lot of mystery here in this >> The
friend pointed it out to me and I was like, "Oh, nice." Oh, I
listen. I've said as much as I can. It sounds like Willie was
like shaken up because a screenshot of the top of a video that
was supposedly you opening
in a in a VC media player thing. Alleged material in VLC media.
Sounds like that kind of freaked him the out. >> Ethan's
the lawsuit guy. Um, like I said before, and you can go read
my court filings. Almost every single thing I talk about on stream
ends up thrown in some court filing. The >> Bro, this guy
just starts Dude, this guy accused Pixie and posted screenshots
of her saying she used fake IDs to get behind a bar. Oh, this
is like Carl Job right now. This guy's been running his mouth
all the time.
What was Ebston's reason for skipping that part of the video?
It was that he's in an active court case and it has to do with
those conversations, which is weird. It was very weird. Okay.
Okay. Why was he trying to actively dox somebody who was a part
of his active court case? Sorry. Why Why was he trying to use
Kiwi Farms to dox somebody
who was a part of his court case? Why wasn't he using some legal
method to do that?
Isn't that weird? Yeah, I understand it keeps getting in there,
but now all of a sudden when it's convenient, I've got to shut
this one down, guys. I can't talk about it
>> Yeah,
dude. It's crazy. Nick Ed Dude,
we're arriving. Okay, Nicholas is catching up. Nicholas is catching
up. We have to understand. We have to be understanding of other
people. They'll take some time to catch up. >> We should
be understanding. Okay, >> The ability for me to maneuver
in an environment where people are spamming the FBI on me. Okay.
And then where I have a civil litigant against me who is the
most latigious insane person of the world. Actually, true. Once
again, Nicholas, I still had some charity for this guy. Welcome,
Nicholas. Okay, you're back. You're in a familiar place. You
are the last guy off the bus again.
The last off the bus every time. Well, I still kind of have some
charity for this Destiny guy. Why? How? I guess this lie about
Willie and me telling Willie that he should make the video. Okay,
that lie. That's the final straw. I'm done with this guy. Good
one. >> Good one. >> Um the idea that I'm supposed
to just divulge more and more and more and more and more information.
>> But you choose to do this willingly when it's convenient
to you. or maybe you're just a horror cow and you can't control
it. I don't really care which one. But it is really convenient
that we're just not going to talk about thisation
to not even deal with. It's not like there's even like if there
was some victim that had come forward and was saying like, "Oh,
this person abused me." It's like, "Okay, my idea to make." But
it's not even that, right? It's just people digging through and
like, "Oh, I think that this happened and blah and this happened
and we need it." It's like you. No, that's stupid. If he doesn't
like my answer for that, Mr. Lawsuit guy, um, I don't know. Like
I said, he can be my first interview after my lawsuit finishes
if he wants to chat. You need to debunk all the random lies.
No, I don't think I do. >> Oh, that's convenient.
>> One, because >> No, no, no. We put out uh Ethan
Klein's 15-year-old Reddit account where he makes a bunch of
jokes and stuff, so I think I'm off the hook on this one. Okay,
cool. >> A lot of them are not debunk.
>> Dude, Nicholas is unaware that Destiny got a deal from
the FBI. Okay, guys. If you're not aware, if Destiny exposes
three,
they let him go on the child stuff. Okay, he's just got to expose
three P and they let him off the hook. That's the That's the
new program. Okay, three for one. If he can find three P and
expose them, they just let him go. He's Yeah, no problem guy.
Yeah, we forget about all this all this Rose. Okay, all this
all this seam. We forget about all of it. Okay, he's got 20 to
bargain with. He doesn't have to give up all these.
He's got to spare. He can get into this multiple more times.
because um
I think that it really
can make random unhinged. >> Does this sound performative
enough to do
like you say? >> Just curious again. That's a Oh, it's
so performative. Willy's calling me shaking cuz he thought you
sent him a screenshot of of obviously cropped. Wait, did Lily
didn't think that he was like implicated that he had like
Right. I could see a law saying if you transmit an artifact from
like a child's abuse material video, you're you're in trouble.
But just receiving like something that you can't even see is
I would imagine there's just no possible way you could be in
trouble for that, right? Like
I don't know why Willie be freaking out necessarily, but like
other than oh this guy's truly disgusting. Maybe that, but in
terms of his culpability, I don't know. I don't see how you >> video
that you cropped that that again. Like yeah, I'm sorry. >> Except
it's possible. It's possible he's in one of those states where
it's a mandatory thing, >> dude. I don't know. random whatever
things. Um, and then you have to come out and start divulging
more and more information in order to fight it off. Nah, [__]
You're right. I didn't >> That's cringe. That's cringe,
bro. >> And just to be clear, Willie was not sent just
for the clippers out there. He was sent the time the time code
or whatever of a crop VLC media player >> Oh, this was
the >> Okay, so now he
was sent a screenshot that included part of the frame, but >> finds
the Willie Mac Show stuff so he could play victim to his audience.
Be like, "Oh, oh, he showed it. It was so >> details to
come out before I comment. This is not why I went to the police.
It's because he continued to write. I didn't know.
>> So his um he zoomed by it really fast,
>> yeah. Again, they're all on Twitter. >> I don't
I don't think that's a good al Oh, he zooms by it really fast,
dude. Everything he says there, like if you just look at what
Willie actually says, right, which is uh where does he say he's
not making a video? He literally says, "Uh, I have no reason
to be suspicious now. And as long as like you aren't suspicious
to me, I'm not going to do anything with this. Like he actually
gives a condition where I'm not going to attempt to hide it.
>> This uh I'm not going to make a vid on any of this because
right now there isn't proof that you knew or suspicious. But
if that exists, that's really bad. Like you said, super red flag.
Like the idea that >> Yeah, it's you. He talked to you
in a completely different way prior to that like one inciting
incident. >> This h wonder why that might be. >> He's
going to be publishing this conversation. Oh, guys, we are uh
we're at 45 minutes left on the stream. If you want to donate
more time to the stream, okay, uh sub, donate the exclamation
point, donate in the chat, okay? There's kickbot link there.
All right. Uh you can sub, you can gift, you can give subs, okay?
You can donate, buy a TTS message, anything you want to do. We
are, I think, still six.
Yeah, six subs away from their out on the stream. And now I have
to like line by line that I'm just like spitballing to this [__]
ridiculous. Not listen if I wasn't in a current again remember
this person is asking for $15 million the um pixie prison for
this lawsuit. I'm good on that one. Okay. I'm not I'm not going
to be fighting this a court of the public opinion and in the
court of uh the Southern District of Florida at the same time.
So but yeah. >> So that's Destiny talking about it. Has
has Nick gone through the part where I wonder if he's gone through
that because it just feels so critical to me to just keep pointing
out that Destiny keeps saying he wants to opt out of this after
giving the information away after himself providing the critical
piece of info to prove that this girl was a minor and kick this
whole thing back off again. It is what it is. Just to be clear
though, I clipped this today. This is about like 3 hours ago,
but Willie has already responded to him here. weird because when
I asked Destiny if he had se Sam on his computer, he told me,
"Depends on why you're asking and gave me a bunch of reasons
why he has on his computer." Willie has made absolutely no attempt
to suppress the reason why he's exposed Destiny.
It is not like the It's not the Wizard of Oz here. There's no
curtain to go. You don't have to follow the yellow brick road
to figure it out. It's literally a 4-minute video that is extremely
straightforward that he's not showing on stream. Okay? He didn't.
And by the way, when you say, "Oh, I can't watch this because
of my court case." That was the same excuse he used with Ryan
Beard. Oh, I mean, I got a thing going on right now. I can't
watch this Ryan Beard video.
But he watched Ethan Klein talk about the things from the Ryan
Beard, some things from the Ryan Beard video, and it was like
had people saying, "Oh, guys, he responded to the Ryan Beard
video through by proxy. Obviously by proxy, >> even when
like 75% of the video had nothing to do with [__]
Pixie. You could have watched entire segments of it where Pixie
wasn't even mentioned. But that's besides the point. It's just
I hope Pixie gets back up from all of this and reboots Sugar
and Spice.
>> Well, well, well, Steve Dave, thank for the five gifted.
We are one sub or $6 away from another from another hour on the
stream, guys. Let's go get those subs in. >> So, I don't
think this is going to happen. Nando, do you do you know why
I don't think it's going to happen that Sugar and Spice gets
restarted? Because based on Loaderbox still having a ton of heat
for straight raid,
um I don't think that Pixie and Straight Raider are ever getting
along again. All right.
Like Loaderbox went through this entire video that Ethan put
out or the entire like Ethan plus Destiny react and his like
one comment I caught from him. The one comment I caught that
was like tangibly related was like, "Oh, Straighter's mention.
How is she connected to this? Oh, I don't know. I don't know
how she got out of this. She like slithered away." It's like
I How is the person in this that you have the most heat that
you specify the most heat for straight raid somehow? How the
is that possible? I don't get it. Now, I didn't watch the beginning
of his react of the Destiny stuff, I don't think. Or did I? No,
I don't think so. So, I didn't catch all of it. Might have had
a lot of heat for Destiny. I think he generally has heat for
Destiny. I just think it's weird when you watch uh Ethan Klein
lay out exactly why Destiny's like super up for doing this and
your your one comment is oh trade raid or one of maybe three
or four comments is trader raid it just seems weird to me that's
all fodder for his sickopantic fans to go >> I don't think
lonerbox likes destiny I don't think that but I >> unfortunately
when you give that impression off when you don't have any actual
heat for the guy okay like >> going spam in everybody's
videos while he sits there goes, "Okay, guys. I told them to
>> Oh, is Limbo Gaggin still here? He wanted me to go over
that thread and I would go over it. Um, but if he's not around,
I might wait. >> Stand down. Okay, dude. Yeah. Awesome.
It's just ammunition for those people to swing in." All right.
Um, so that's that. So, again, Destiny posted this tweet saying
Destiny Willie Max show Ethan Klein, right? But I think it's
a bit more like this tweet where it's Destiny swinging his tax
folder. Yes, that is Ana Jooha in there just to be safe. Anisha
Joha for reference into his hard drive and Willy's like, "No,
what are you doing?" I think that's probably a bit more accurate
as to what I think is going on here. So, this is um Oh man, a
lot of money in this. That's all I could That's what I when I
see this, I'm like, there's a lot of money in this. A lot of
money here. >> Again, I think this is pretty fair. I'm
going to go, you know, now now that we've gone through my whole
response of this guy just continuing to lie about me for the
last couple of days. Uh is there anything else I wanted to show
here? I think it's this one, right? Uh, what is this? No. Oh,
yeah. We need this. We're going to get to this in a second. Um,
this is We're not going to get to this till much later, but I
do think I want this in this segment. Is it? Let me see. Is it
this?
Oh, I don't know where I put it. There's an additional clip.
I don't know. I'll pull it up later. Oh, I think it's okay. So,
just to be clear, let's talk about this this situation because
this situation is the one that's been completely like ignored
now because this whole thing about Ethan Klein and all the stuff
that we're going to watch later. I do want to spend like five
minutes talking about it. So, just to be clear, from the information
that I was able to deduce, I didn't have five full hours of research
like Destiny put into his Ethan Klein video, so this might not
be very accurate. I don't know. Who knows? Um, Destiny was notified
on 2411. It's UK, I believe. Uh, he was he was notifi not. Okay,
so this is before the videos were released too on um November
20. So, Adessie says like this guy had just had just like released
child released to me. He had not yet to be clear that he had
not leaked the videos yet as far as I know on the 24th. I think
it's 26th 29th. I think it's 29th of November
>> that he was potentially in like he had potential on
his hard drive. Right. Again, I understand this is the leaker.
They might not be uh the most fair person to talk to. It's like
a Kiwi Farm leaker. It's like the worst of all scenarios, right?
But the Kiwi Farm leaker who had access to all this stuff and
published it on the internet told Steven that he was potentially
holding material since 2022.
I don't know about you, but if I was told that I had material
on my hard drive, uh the first thing I would do is report that
to law enforcement, report that to someone because obviously
the intention wasn't to have that in on my computer. Not saying
that's evidence of destiny wanting it, but I'm just saying that's
how my brain would work, okay? Because if I'm accused of having
this material, uh, my first thought isn't, um,
Oh, dude.
Apparently, Ball Goku is back. Hold on a second. I just noticed
his reply on one of my tweets. Apparently, the Ball Goku guy
is back. Give me a second. He just he responded to the Nick tweet.
The tweet about like Nick and me laughing about him realizing
that Destiny lies and the last bit of his charity being gone
cuz Destiny's Destiny's lying about me. And he just responds
with cope. He just respond he just responds with cope
Uh what is what is the cope here exactly? That is it that Destiny
doesn't lie or
I let me see here. Would you stop talking to a girl if she couldn't
immediately identify which movie this iconic Captain America
look was from? I'm sorry that Steven Destiny Benel 2 post Viviance.
Wow. Imagine reactivating on Twitter to dick ride this hard.
This is pretty crazy. This is pretty This is pretty nuts.
Oh, hold on. I want all of the chatters who totally took this
guy's side. Okay. I want you all to remember what you were just
talking about. Okay. All right.
Coming back to Twitter now after being off of it for a few years
would be like going into a coma in Germany in 1940 and waking
up in 1950. Wash is back to posting on Twitter. Let's go.
Wash is
You lose when you die. Hope. Why delete it if they were just
jokes. Ethan, I I just think this is interesting. Okay. He's
been on Twitter just on an adult alt. Okay. Came back just when
Destiny needed it most. I don't think he can sweep this one.
Okay. I don't think it's
Let's keep listening to Nick here. >> How do I get to keep
it? It's Holy. I got to get this away from me as fast as possible.
Okay. Are you Do you have a Okay. Okay. Ogre boy. I'm sorry.
You don't get to judge him. All right.
I'm sorry. I I get that you're like, "Never in my life would
I ever." But I'm not going to You don't get to judge him. Okay.
You don't you don't >> mental attachment to these naked
videos and pictures. Is there any reason to not delete these
immediately? Well, the thing that people have been telling me
is it was because Destiny was being sued. Only >> Nope.
Massive >> that is this is November 24th. Okay, just for
context, according to Pixie's lawsuit, she only found out that
she was in the leaks on November 29th. So what that means is
there were five full days from when Destiny was just crashing
out finding out that his was all over the internet to the time
when Pixie found out that her video was on the internet. So not
only was Pix No. Oh. Oh. Nick has this up. No, no, no, no. This
is the evening. This is when they leaked is November 29th. So
there were no video leaks. Destiny could have been crashing out
about him sucking dick on the internet because the video leaks,
I don't believe until the 29th.
Someone someone correct me if I'm wrong here. At least the 26th.
I'm I'm 90% sure. 29th. 10% 26th.
Not suing. This was 5 days where Destiny didn't even know he
was going to be sued. This is 5 days where Pixie didn't even
know she was going to sue Destiny or that she'd have to. So why
keep it,
dude? November 24th. Okay. November 29th. I again I think the
average person a normal person within those five days reports
this to law enforcement submits this like FBI tip I don't know
and gets this off of their drives I don't think that they clone
it and put it elsewhere but again Destiny saying he didn't do
that now this conflicting
>> uh Sage Mage thank you for the four >> reports
on what he actually has on his hard drive to be fair to him so
now let's keep going we got November uh November 24th he finds
out that he might be in possession of CC >> so then you
go from the 29th the video leaks. Okay. I think you get a whole
like seven weeks, eight weeks where he doesn't do anything before
the actual January 20th comes uh comes due. Okay. The the Sunday
video drops, Pixie announces the lawsuit. Um Cherry finds out
and tweets like that's the January 20th. Okay. That's when that's
when the lawsuit factor comes in. All right. First leak is the
20th is in the DM leaks, the Lauren Southern DM leaks. And then
the revenge forms is on the 29th. Okay. Got it. >> Sam
got it. Okay. Okay. By the guy who leaked all of this to begin
with and knows the person specifically. All right. Uh November
29th. Okay. This is when Pixie even finds out that she's in the
leaks and confronts Steven. Okay. Then January 20th is when Pixie
puts out the Substack. All right. So, this is about the time
that she gets outed by President Sunday. Right.
Then, this is actually out of order. I'm sorry. My bad. One more
time. November 24th. >> For the love of God, please, Nick.
I just I want him to read those Destiny messages in the right
order. Please don't read them talking. >> Solo mentions
that the minor stuff, right? Um anyway, she was underage while
sending you the vast majority of that stuff. And from what I've
heard about her, you were pretty negligent in confirming her
age, right? And Destiny goes, I confirmed her age, right? November
29th, Pixie finds out about it.
And on December 3rd, Destiny's talking about if she's a minor,
I'm probably done. So, he was stewing about this for about 10
days and at no point thought, "Oh, I should try to get this in
touch. I got to get to law enforcement. I got to go talk to this
person." This seems like conclusive proof that he thought it
was a possibility she was a minor, right? Like, it's just conclusively
proven that he thinks it's possible she's a minor.
He was informed and then conclusively he thinks it's a possibility.
He knows he didn't check. He knows he didn't make sure. I go
talk to that person, right? Uh, now obviously in the month of
December there were rumbles that Pixie was going to sue Destiny.
So maybe at that point his brain went to, "Oh, I've got to save
everything. I'm getting sued." But it doesn't really answer why
he's doing this like the first 5 days,
but it's something on his mind. He's thinking, "Oh my god, this
person might be a minor." >> So Pixie exposes Destiny uh
after the President Sunday video on January the 20th. Right after
that happens, the lawsuit is filed.
It appears we we got the paperwork on February 9. Nick would
be in a pretty good place to attack Destiny if he hadn't picked
out and run from you and Queman. No, he can attack Destiny just
fine. He has not been attacking Destiny because of I would say
Queman and I. Um maybe more even Quimman. Um for Nick, I think
Queman operates a or occupies a way bigger space in Nick's head
than I do. I don't think Nick really hates me that much. Or sorry,
I don't I don't know how much Nick hates me, but I I think Queman
for for Nick is a way bigger problem. Um Willie hates me. Willie
has like a personal hatred for me that is crazy. But uh I'd say
in Nick's head, it's it's more Queman. Um and and that's why
he hasn't been going because Destiny will attack us and that's
just convenient for Nick, right? So he has not been going after
Destiny. Hasn't been calling Destiny a liar. He's just he's just
let Destiny go buck wild and not called him out. See here. I
think Nick is afraid of Destiny's audience considering he told
Sunday that in their call. That might be true, but he's already
like gone after Destiny, right, for some of the [__]
he was saying. So maybe that that could be true to kill Sunset.
I I think to some extent it is, but he's already like on the
bad side of Destiny. I think the reason he was letting it go,
the reason he wasn't calling Destiny out with all of the lies
is because it was convenient for him to have somebody like slandering
Queen and I when when he felt like we didn't like him or respect
him or treat him with due deference, I guess. >> 19th.
All right.
>> Don't you have a personal hatred for Willie, too? Yeah,
but mine's based on his like personal acts towards me. Willy's
is based on schizophrenia. Like Will, my my hatred for Willie
is him just lying about me repeatedly, amplifying Desty's lies
about me, right? And some of the stuff he's DM' me, but Willy's
hatred for me is like we had that argument and then he's just
seethed privately and been schizophrenic.
There's a lot of time between there's a whole lot of time here
to make a whole lot of decisions. All right. And then now fast
forward to August. >> A lot of people hate you for some
reason. Uh I can be abrasive. I could be like uh I I'm not like
um super lovable. Red 473. All right. Um there's a indirectness
to the way I criticize people sometimes that people can find
really annoying. So I don't I'm not like perfect or something.
I would say a lot of it does have to do with that um that Willie
conversation in my opinion. That Willie conversation and then
the commentary like basically Nicholas's reaction to it. I think
there's a lot of it built from there, but I won't say it's all
of it or even um the majority of it. I'm probably just I'm probably
hatable on my own just fine. Okay, 2025.
All right, now we're in a position where it's Willy Mack. You're
sending me this. I guess you're I'm glad you saw the video. Oh,
yeah. Depends on why you're asking. So, this is Willie Mack talking
to Destiny where he implies that he created copies of all of
the messages and everything when the court case started. So,
when the court case started, just be clear. Okay, this one this
one this is it. Yeah, this one that started um presumably he
had already started before that, but yeah.
Perfect. We solved that problem. No more co-hosts. Look, we're
we're done with that. We're we're just solo now. Okay. So, awesome.
We We solved that problem completely. Let's go. That's the court
case. Um, so yeah, that's another thing. But then, all right,
while that's happening, while he tells Willie Max show that he
has archives of all of this and you still have the video, then
he says, "Yeah, it depends on why uh you're asking. I created
the copy of all the messages." Then he goes on stream, okay,
before watching the video. Come on, man. Why didn't you include
the book? without saying anything. And in my opinion, from what
I can deduce, he just lies about it >> like at some point.
Yeah.
Honestly, should watch the Mac video. He's literally saying you
have 60 gigs of in your computer. I mean, like I said, I've already
addressed this. Like this chick sent me >> I don't think
you specifically addressed the part that people have deduced
that she's most likely 18. I mean, I most likely 17, right? Like
I think that I don't think you've specifically addressed that
um in regards to this drama. I think that you >> He has
addressed it in his own chat. He has said that there is no conclusive
evidence. That is a lie. There is
infinite conclusive evidence. Okay, there's like four different
pieces of conclusive evidence that show that this person is was
17 at the time. Especially the most important thing, 17 for the
time stamp that for the Willie DMs. Okay, so Willie throws I
think he has a reply here. Am I crazy? Is it a reply that he
does to himself? I thought it was his own reply to himself that
shows the other DMs, but I can't see them now. which is weird.
Uh Willie Mac Show media. Let me just go to his media tab. It'll
be here somewhere. So, this frame is from VC. This clearly shows
like the top of somebody's head, right? Screen recording 2022,
August 14th, 3 p.m.
3:15. Okay. Skype screen recording.
She was 17 when this video was recorded,
he says. But the videos she record with other guys, the file
names are like this. Her boyfriend was recording these on Skype
calls. That's just absolutely insane. It is a video where she
is 17. That is objectively
what we have here. That is a screen cap from a video from a video.
That is a that is a screen cap from child that Destiny has kicking
around, right? Like that's what that is. And and he pretends
that that's not what it is. And he's confused about why
he's freaked out. people who defend you are literally saying
they've seen the evidence and it's most likely it it would it
would take an act of God for this not to be a 17-year-old the
time that you were like exchanging with her, right? Like that
would that would literally have to be like an act of God for
that to be the case, right? >> Right. Yeah.
>> Also, in this clip that you're about to see, he clings
to the 60 gigs part cuz he can prove that, but he doesn't really
address anything else. >> You should watch the Mac video.
He's literally saying you have 60 gigs of in your computer. Man,
like I said, I've already addressed this. Like this chick sent
me um
a screenshot of a folder that she said that her and her ex of
stuff they made, but I I mean I don't have this on my computer.
>> Does Nick pick up on the on my computer part? Does he
pick up on that? That's an important part. >> I don't even
think I told Will. >> So most charitable interpretation
is I don't have 60 gigs of it on my computer.
>> Uh no, I think most charitable interpretation is none
of it's on my computer, but it's still in my possession, right?
I think that's the most charitable interpretation is I don't
have any of that on my computer anymore, but I have it in my
possession still. Hard drive, cloud drive, something. If he put
it on a cloud drive, it's like so ballgame. I People keep saying,
"Oh, he's got a Google Drive account with it." I think that's
really stupid. If people think it's a like a Google that would
be he is automatically done. You cannot go and like run magnets
across a Google like a cloud drive, right? Like that is going
to be retained. You It's over if that's what's happened. I think
it has to be some hard drive. He has like kind of hard drive
setups. He has lots of extra hard drives because of podcast having
the hard drives in the the cameras and stuff. I think he's got
like his own reason to run his own like raid setup or something.
I think he's got a lot of extra hard drives sitting around,
but I I view it just as like a lie by omission. And I think that
most people would as well.
>> I don't even think I told Willie I have this on my computer,
so I have no idea why he's >> Oh, Willie must have fabricated
it.
No, no, we didn't. Dude, I think Destiny has a thing where unless
there's no other option, he won't outright lie. Like, he's got
a phobia or some like he's got some OCD thing where like lying
is is offputting to him. And so, he won't lie, but he tells on
himself all the time, right? You know how that is? Like like
like when he says he just has to keep saying on my computer.
I never told Billy I had this on my computer.
It's it's like a actual OCD thing where unless he it's the only
way out of a situation, he will not outright lie, but he will
totally he he will like lie by omission. He'll he'll be indirect.
He will he will leave things out. He'll do so many That's lying
by omission, but he'll do so many different things while not
technically by the transcript lying, but it like it leads to
him telling on himself with stuff like this. It's very weird.
But I I I view it just as like a lie by omission. And I think
that most people would as well.
>> No, but but uh Shelk, this is him lying, right? But
when he's like talking about his own actions, he he will try
not to outright lie about them. I guess lie about other people,
not a problem. Lying about the things he's done or or or whatever.
It seems to he seems to have something there. It's weird. There's
a criminology term for this. I forget what it is called. Person
in interrogation do it all the time. JCS talks about it. Oh,
were they like they want to make sure that they're maintaining
the truth? >> I told Willie I have this on my computer,
so I have no idea why he's >> Oh, Willie must have fabricated
it.
>> No, no, he didn't. I guess Nick Dioro made him say that.
>> I don't know if Willie posted any of our DMs, but my
message to Willie was um she told me she was 19 and she was in
college and we were chatting. If she was actually 17, people
should be asking why that solo guy had recorded like 60 GB of
with her plus all the other guys she recorded stuff with. Um,
and then I'm pretty sure even Solo said that she lied about her
age to me in that KB form thread somewhere. >> Guys, this
is like it's not like a pyro Carson. We're talking about a 33y
old man here, just to be clear. All right. Um, I I I don't care
about any close in age exception 21 22 YouTubers. That doesn't
matter to me in this context, right? And by the way, I'm also
not making an argument that like he was specifically seeking
out a 17-year-old. What I'm saying is in 20 >> Hold on.
Hold on. Fraga Nick says, "He's just directly pariting the KF
narrative, isn't he?" Uh-oh.
Willie, get down. Willie, you're a valid military target, Willie.
Get down.
You don't want to be You don't want to be in this group, Willie.
I think they're they're about to about to tee off on you right
now. 24 somebody informed him that he might have had CSA material
and then we found out in 2025 in August that he still has it
and then he doesn't have it and then he posted in his statement
he doesn't have it and now he just can't talk about it. I'm a
little concerned here. I don't know. I feel like this is a bit
>> statement he doesn't have it and now he just can't talk
about it. I'm a little concerned here.
>> I don't know. I feel like this is a bit concerning,
chat. Bit concerning. >> I think all of Solo's original
posts were deleted. I'm not sure. >> You could like the
the way you walk through this is very very simple with regards
to Willy's
DMs. Okay. Right. It's uh Hold on. Hold on. Is this where he
starts them? Where does he start his actual DMs here? What the
[__] Let me go back. Right here. Right here. Go back
one. Okay.
So, Desessie sends the the screen cap or whatever. Right. Willie
says, "If you're sending me this, I'm guessing you still have
the video." Depends on why you're asking, but yes, I create a
copy. So, that is a yes, I still have that video. Willie goes,
he clarifies. Willie clarifies, "Bro, there's been allegations
since at least my last vid that she was underage and you still
have potential of her. If Willie was incorrect in what he was
saying that Destiny did not have a video at all and oh no, Will,
you're misunderstanding me." Destiny just goes, "Oh, no, no,
I don't have potential. I've gotten rid of all that stuff." what
I meant was I retained like logs and stuff like kind of a record
that I was sent the video. But he doesn't say that. He he corrects
this by saying I have an obligation to preserve relevant evidence.
Well, he says that's nuts, man. Further indicating, hey, the
fact that you still have the video of her is crazy. And Destiny
says I don't think I'm allowed to delete it. Lol. What is it?
What is it? It refers to something specific.
What is it in this context? There's only one possible it.
It's the child video that he just sent the screen cap to Willie
of or whatever that he's referencing. I think he sent the screen
cap before this. I'm actually not 100% sure if he sent it before
after. Uh let's see here. Yeah. It's just insane to think she
was 17 doing all of this with him.
Yeah. No, he had just sent it. Yes. So, it's the screen cap.
That's it. It's the video. It's the video.
It's the video.
Okay. Like, I'm sorry. There's just no other way to look at this.
There's only one possible interpretation. >> Could have
had a whole another child in the time that it went from Steven
finding out that he potentially had CCM material to to right
now. He could have had a whole child in that time period. >> But
yeah, I don't I don't have this on my computer. I'm not sure.
But yeah, I don't I don't have this on my computer. >> I
don't know if I believe you. I don't know if I blame anybody
either. your boy Ski. I think he's he's like basically after
being online for so long, he leaves these things um
he like tries not to say anything that could be used against
him later, right? I think it's a habit from being online and
expecting things to get leaked. I think so. >> It's a lot
of silence
for a person of Adderall.
I don't know if he's not at all, but I boogie bag. He's pretty
hard right here, dude. He's pretty JF's girlfriend. >> This
video does make me look insane. Oh
>> You thought I paused. No, he was doing his best denims
impression. only forgot the video. It inverted his son share
reaction where he's there and the content's missing. Yeah, definitely
found out. So, >> who just left? Okay, somebody clipped
this for Nick. Nick, you got to fire whoever clipped this for
you. They just left like 20 seconds of dead air in at the end
of this clip. The [__] >> That's my response
to Destiny. I think this is the important stuff. I think that
this stuff got completely overlooked. I think that partially
Ethan is responsible uh for the way he doubled down, but like
ultimately
Destiny's whole argument about the Hassan thing is that this
stuff doesn't like it doesn't matter when you overcommit and
doesn't matter when you're like um per like basically performative
the way you attack people specifically in the Klein incident.
Um and I argue that it does matter and Destiny then uses that
to his advantage here to try to sweep this under the rug and
not talk about it. And look, all right, yeah, people are going
to leave. People are going to unfollow me. They're going to call
me a who's talking about no evidence.
Destiny is far worse than Hassan. That seems like such an easy
point to make. And I feel like you look so stupid when you don't
agree to that point. Like realistically, you don't that doesn't
mean one of them is a good person. Just means like one of them
is slightly closer to him. Okay?
And it should be so easy for you to admit this that Destiny is
far worse than Hassan. >> That I'm slandering people. I'm
showcasing stuff on purpose to maliciously attack people. None
of that's true. But you know, I'll tell you one thing. I want
you to go and if I can find you first, I'll be happy to shut
the door behind you. Okay? I'll be happy to throw your ass out
of my community. All right? If you're getting on your knees and
sucking this guy's this late in the game, there is no reason
on planet Earth. There's no Okay, hold on. There's no way Nick
is making that [__] argument right now. Nick, Nick,
Nick, we've already made it clear you and Willie are the last
two people off the bus. Nick, come on, man. All right. If you're
getting on your knees and sucking this guy's this late in the
game, there is no reason on planet Earth to be defending this
guy in August of 2025. Listen, I might have stayed on the ship
for too long, but you guys have been staying past the point where
this the dude where the Titanic. It's 20,000 ft under the water
right now. The submer >> Okay, that that was a little better.
He did a little of himself >> just exploded. It's time
to get out of the water. Okay, this guy's full of I just showed
you an hour of him lying about me in the context that is kind
of he's talking his sweeper hunting. I literally just get annoyed
about the Willie thing. The the militia's lying and Nicholas
supporting it. Nicholas not calling it out. And then he watches
this and he's like, I can't believe Destiny's just lying about
me, Willie. What? Why can't you believe that? Serious towards
the end there. All right. Why the would I believe anything else
he has to say about this? He's already proven that he's a manipulative
nar narrator. The guy's not giving you the answers. Oh, well,
he can't because of his court case. What he said about Ryan Beard
played part of his video recently. I don't know, man. Oh, can't
knock him. I can't do anything. It'll jeopardize my court case.
Well, that pink pixie, let's be fair. You were over to the year,
buddy. Yes. Uh, yeah. That's That's
Do you think I've uh do you think I've come to terms with that
and have the correct opinions on this? I'm I'm annoyed with Nick
supporting Destiny's totally malicious like fanfiction
3 weeks ago. Four weeks ago. That's what I'm annoyed about. I'm
not avoid annoyed about a year ago. Hey, for underage drinking
or something and using a fake ID to get behind a bar.
Oh, but they put it all in the thing. It's like the guy's a rage
cow. He's lashing out. He's doing any damage he possibly can.
He doesn't give a [__] about being correct. And if
you want to go down with that [__] be my guest. All
right? Because if you you Oh, Nick, I don't I used to respect
you. It's like, bro, I don't give a [__] who respects
me on this at all whatsoever. To me, you're just another name
in the chat. You'll be replaced. How is anybody saying I don't
respect you? He's just being like, Destiny's a liar. I don't
want to defend this guy at all. This guy sucks. And somebody
apparently is saying, Nick, I don't respect you to that. Find
that person. That person is not safe to be around children or
women. Okay? Find that person, mark them for the good of society,
okay? They need they need to be tracked, right? At the beginning
of the next drama, your spot in line will be taken by somebody
else. So, yeah, that's my stance. Um, if you don't like it, go
[__] yourself. Let's start the rest of uh Nick's
not up the talking points that badly. You boy, he's not [__]
up the talking points that badly. I haven't been to a cabal meeting
in a while. I I think I think Queman and I agree on what the
talking point should be here.
I'll have to I'll have to book a meeting. Okay. I I I haven't
been to a Cabal meeting in a little while. I think it's supposed
to be Okay. Destiny doxed the minor he was himself. He he worked
with Kiwi Farms. He released additional information that only
he had to dox the minor he was
thus proving she was a minor creating the controversy. Beyond
your computer focus is a up. Okay, that's a but like it's leading
to the correct talking points which is laughing about Destiny
clearly making it very clear that he still has this and doing
like the little plausible deniability thing with I don't have
it
on my computer. I don't have that stuff. I've never seen child
in my entire life. I've never seen it uh in any way that's on
my computer. Um, but you know, it's really weird that you would
It was never, you know, on my streaming computer's hard drive.
It's like,
okay, hey, uh, this guy got murdered in your garage.
Okay. And I'm curious like, what were you doing on Thursday?
And somebody's like, I've, uh, I've never killed someone in my
garage.
Is that right?
That's that's kind of like what it is. Okay, that's not quite
it. I I [__] up that analogy, but I'm just going
to move forward and pretend I didn't try it. So, it's something
like that. It's like you're giving a detail that like makes it
clear you still could have murdered them. It wouldn't be in the
garage. Somebody got murdered in your kitchen. It's like I've
never murdered somebody in my bedroom.
It's like that. That's not what I asked. Have did Did you kill
this guy? I've never murdered somebody
in the living room. I've never killed somebody
with a gun. Well, that that guy was stabbed. I've never killed
anybody on a day that starts with S.
It's like, okay, can you stop doing the weird qualifiers? It's
making me think you killed somebody. Okay, stop stop making me
stop convincing me that you killed somebody. It's weird
to the show. Donations are
>> I just saw Ke's tweet on. >> Why so mad? I think
that having Cam is bad and I think that's the most performative
thing I ever said. >> Stinks bat in 1000 while everyone
else >> We haven't done one of those types of streams in
a while, but yeah. All right, now we get to the fun stuff. We're
going to be doing ultimate
Reddit review.
>> Okay, boom. Done with the next segment. I got one clip
left on the Destiny stuff and then I'm moving on. I think we're
going to just do the kick house. Okay, the kick house clips.
The kick house clips. I believe that's where we're going. Wait,
there's no way I have two laundry tweets, right? No. Okay, guys,
that clip I was playing yesterday, there's a wider shot to that
clip. It's Destiny talking about the Cristia situation. All right.
And there's a wider shot to that clip. There's more context there
that makes it even
worse somehow. You you wouldn't think it's possible. Okay. You
wouldn't think it possible, but it does somehow get worse. That
whole the wider shot of that. Okay. When you get the context
around that, it is so much so much worse. >> An underage
person or did he actually meet or trade nudes with or what's
the what what are the accusations right now? Multiple underage
girls.
Okay. I'm sorry. I said this again.
Listen, if you're into like if you're a Okay, I can understand.
Well, not really, but like you shouldn't be, but like
why 17y olds?
Why not just 18y olds?
Just one year, one year later and you're >> Huh? This guy's
like kind of sp Yeah. Yeah.
What? I mean, it's still creepy, but at least you're in the like
legal clear. Nobody be talking about you. Why
17 year olds?
Why not just 18 year olds? Even 16 year olds?
Why not just 18y olds? Like you're so close to it being legal.
You're a
Just do that. Like now listen, that wouldn't quite get him here.
Okay? So hopefully he just leaves it there and then, you know,
he could he could argue, well, I tried to make sure she was 18
and he'd be okay, right? if he just stopped talking there. But
unfortunately for all of us, okay, fortunately for all of us,
Unfortunately for him, he continues.
Guarantee you that all of these guys get DMs from underage girls.
Have you? Yeah, of course. People Sometimes people DM me and
it's like, oh, I always ask, "How old are you?" And sometimes
like, "Oh, I'm 16." I'm like, "Oh, cool. Well, look me up in
3 years." Black, I'm not getting baited by any of that cuz I
know some of you are out there trying to catch me, okay? I'm
too smart for you. Don't even try it. Wow. How creative did she
have to get to to get around your uh your your creativity? Okay.
How creative does she have to get to get around your sensors
here? Looks like she um
she sent you no evidence she was over 18.
Oh, okay. Well, cool. >> Isn't the problem that he was
the one that started the DMs? Oh, maybe. I don't know. But regardless,
I mean, if he started even dumber, >> he keeps going. >> So
[__] stupid. >> He keeps going. Honestly, I
really wouldn't rule out that 17-year-old girls could have lied
about their age or generally played it off to an older guy. Okay,
but like look at the girl's Instagram. Does she have pictures
of her graduating high school or does she have pictures of her
like on the junior so like softball team or some [__]
It should be pretty easy looking at somebody's Instagram to find
out. And if you're a celebrity, you should probably be playing
at like pretty safe.
>> Wow. You could ask for like a social profile. Yeah,
that's true. Holy, this guy's kind of cooking >> anyway,
right? Like I'm at a stage in my life where I I try to air on
the side of caution. Like there have been girls that have messaged
me that have said like they're 19 or 20 or whatever and then
I looked at their Instagram. I was like I'm not sure. I think
I'm going to stop talking to you cuz I'm not even going to f
like Jesus Christ. Like if you have pictures of a girl getting
on a school bus, okay? And the date of this picture is like 2017.
Maybe you should back off a little bit. Okay. Maybe we should
apply a little bit of common sense. All right. And maybe like
calm the down. Um I don't know. Like Okay. Well, you know, even
with all of that, okay, he's he wouldn't he's not totally cooked
himself yet, right? Like, even with all of that, it's not totally
over. All right. He could kind of he kind of be like, "This girl
fooled me. I couldn't see a public profile." Like,
yeah, he plays it close to the line, but the line is legality,
and that's all he's concerned about, right? Like, yeah, you burn
playing it close to the line. >> Like, you're just like,
"Why would you even ride that line? Why would you >> Oh,
be so Why would you Jesus Christ?" Okay. celebrating their sweet
16 in 2019. Maybe it's time to like put the phone down. I think
a lot of celebrities get this idea that these girls have lives
and the rich heroic celebrity wants to fix their life. Maybe
I don't know back cuz sometimes generally what'll happen is if
somebody messages me um initially if they message me and it's
like oh I'm 16 or 17. I be like okay like this is I like talking
to you is like very weird if you bring up anything. Wait
wait I thought it wasn't weird to talk to 16 or 17 year olds.
Oh that's an interesting clip. I thought I thought it was cool
when Drake was messaging Millie Bobby Brown and but like I have
to instant what am I supposed to let her talk to her parents
about block you like it's not worth it but like even on the conversations
that I would entertain it would usually be like some like oh
like my life is so sad and blah blah blah and I don't know what
to do and it's like dude listen I don't know why you're talking
to me for this I can't help you bye like there's like dude there's
just it's you you should be like there are so many holes to fall
into here why would you risk DMS and TXTS confirming he knew
they were >> Yeah, there's like there's just no reason
unless you know like I don't I don't even know what like why
like why would you do this? Like why would you risk it? You've
made it. Like
you did it, dude. You're famous. You're rich. You can [__]
like 95% of the population is probably open to you. Okay.
Why would you risk this? They love underage girls. Find a youngl
looking 20-year-old. Okay, there are girls that are 23, 24 that
look like they're 15. Find one of them. Do some age play. Okay,
daddy daddy little girl. There's kinks out there. Explore your
wild side that way. Why would you? This guy's kind of spitting.
This guy's giving like all of the best advice. If if future Destiny
could just listen to past Destiny, he'd have so many fewer problems.
Okay, >> why would you risk >> Okay, he actually
wouldn't. He's still just a totally He's still a total piece
of But he'd have at least one fewer problem. Why would you go
down the jail road? Why would you do this? So stupid. It's 100%
about power play. Maybe. I guess that's not what daddy daddy
little girl mean, isn't it? I thought it was like age play. I
don't know. I don't do the age kinks. Okay. Well, not where he's
the older one, right? Not where he's the older one. Oh, look.
He doesn't watch other streamers, but he's here now in the chat.
What's up? What's up, Destiny? Apparently, he's mad about my
joke about Kelly. Hold on. Let me pull my joke about Kelly up
on the stream. Give me a second. Thank you, Destiny. This was
this was kind of a banger. I appreciate that you were also a
fan. Uh, what are you virtue signaling about? Why does Jtock
make fun of Kelly for her medical problems when Cherry has the
exact same problems with her vagina? Anyone have any I haven't
experienced this. Did you have a problem with that or I see.
Uhoh. Uh-oh. Destiny had some issues. That's fine.
I heard Kelly has a man on the inside. I think she has a condition
that prevents that, actually.
Desie just posting my bangers for me in chat. Thank you. That's
a joke, by the way. That's not making fun of her. It's just a
joke that happened to work in that moment. Uh, you could say
I'm a piece of [__] for it, I guess. But it's just
a joke. Jokes. Maybe jokes. Oh, maybe JC didn't have that problem
because his dick is small enough to fit
No. No. It's just It's like pretty regular size, buddy. I get
I get how you have problems scaring people, though.
This this guy just comes to chat and self-reports. I don't know.
It's It's a little bizarre. I just love that he Dude, someone
sent me the Queenman time stamp. Okay, cuz I know Que somebody
sent me this clip earlier. Okay, someone someone sent me the
clip
Destiny saying that he doesn't watch other streamers and Queen
pausing and saying, "No, you absolutely watch JCO's stream and
then he's here tonight. Where is it? Hold. I'll find it right
now. I'll just I'll go find it real quick. Queen live. Hold on.
Hold on. Let me go find it. >> Bella, how's Chris doing?
Oh my.
>> Let's Let's see. Let's see. Hold on a second. Let me
see if there's a
Streams.
Streamers.
Streams. Streams. Stream. Streams. My streams.
Come on. Come on. Watch. I don't Here we go. Based on what I've
seen, I don't watch H3 a lot. And I don't mean that as a burn.
I don't watch any content. Anybody that has watched my channel
for any period of time knows I don't watch any content. I just
don't have time or the inclination I should. I just It seems
like most of his crew are like Sims. I know that that a What
is it right now? Okay, it's not 5 in the morning, but it's it's
not 5 in the morning, but other than that, okay, this little
man sees the future every time.